six six six six six six six six six  [Applause]  [Music]  nba honestly you can be a star of the  bench you could be a star in whatever  role if you see the big picture if the  team win  to have a young flat young player trust  in what i say and trust in what we say  that's big because they all have their  own own vision  also  being a father  managing being a father being an nba  player six men in a year and giving us  what we ask from you that's a lot that's  big  took a lot of steps this year man it's  bigger than six minutes a year for you  bro took a lot of steps just being a man  being a professional so i'm proud  let me go ahead  we don't have one of these you know  we ain't got one i think i got like  runner up for like second one here  oh